Let's now elaborate on the goals of operating
systems structure. The first goal is protection. By
protection what we mean is protecting the user
from the system and the system from the user
and also users from one another. And also
protecting an individual user from his or her own
mistakes. That's what we mean by protection. And
this is an important goal of operating system structuring.
An operating system, of course, provides services and
one of the key determinants of a good
operating system structure is how good is the
performance of the operating system. That is, what is
the time taken to perform services on behalf
of the application. I have, you've heard me say
this even before in the previous lecture. A
good operating system is one that provides the service
that is needed by the application very quickly and gets out of the way. And
that's the key determinant of operating system
structure as well. Another goal, of operating system
structure, and in fact, one of the goals that we will be focusing a lot
on in this course module, is flexibility.
Sometimes also called extensibility, meaning that a service
that is provided by the operating system is not one size fits all, but the
service is something that is adaptable to the
requirements of the application. Another important goal of
structuring an operating system is to ensure that
the performance of the operating system goes up
as you add more hardware resources to the
system. This is sort of an intuitive understanding,
but you want to make sure that
the operating system developers on this intuitive understanding
that when you increase the hardware resources,
the performance also goes up, and that's what
is meant by scalability. It turns out that both the needs of the application may
change over the lifetime of an application
and also the resources that are available for
the operating system to manage and give to the application may change over time.
Agility of the operating system refers to
how quickly the operating system adapts itself
to changes either in the application needs
or the resource availability from the underlying
hardware. Another worthwhile goal of operating system
structure would be responsiveness. That is, how quickly
the operating system reacts to external events, and
this is particularly important for applications that are interactive
in nature. Imagine you are playing a video
game. In that case, what you want to see
is when you do something like clicking the
mouse to shoot at a target, you want to
see action immediately on the screen. So that
is responsiveness, how quickly the operating system is reacting
to external events.